most of these are from position
challenges let's do a random one ooh
what is this my pieces are
discombobulated oh but I'm white okay
let's play question which Bishop do I
wanna so I just have a so it's not too
bad I just have um double pawns
everywhere I guess I'll play this move
because I want to free this vision I'm
okay I'm in the control space hopefully
let's play yeah let's play e4 going
through E 5 oh I lost upon ooh not used
to a 3 hanging on move 3 what is this
like it's just sac the exchange yeah
okay it's it's a gambit sacking the
exchange by mu 5
and then I have more space I have some
initiative some idea of probably 94 94
and Queen f4 I'm trying to talk tonight
and also that southern pawn yeah it's
hard to play a London from this position
I need my Bishop here it's hard to build
the hats actually all like all of the
pieces for later are well coordinated
like the bishops have have good spots
Knights are decent rook has a half woven
file the Queen has a square and there's
targets in blacks position
I'm trying to think like how many
impossible starting positions can you
make I guess it's just basically asking
I mean possible legal positions are in
chess but there are there D more
positions you can make because you can
just add like extra layers of pawns so
it's probably some astronomical number
so there's g4 here actually the nice
thing about double D pawns
I can play g4 twice oh I complete g5
twice maybe eventually so like g5 and I
left Knight f5 and then g4 again double
pawns can be twice as good I don't just
like coffee I usually like milk in my
coffee or cream I had coffee earlier
which maybe wasn't the best best
decision
so Rikai feeds
okay let's let's push some some G pawns
and I was really hoping for a 9.5 g4 and
Nike side of it and I was gonna play
Queen s6 and say oh no my queen but
that's a move
I can't Castle oh but I have this move
rook is almost trapped
hmm so if 97 I guess no GE 7 let's go
get interesting
I really want to play this move it's
such a cool move it was a slight issue
with ever g8 it looks so much fun and
the light spins to angie Sutton's week
okay try and calculate
oh no my queen there how the pawns on g7
da ha this looked like such a weak
square I had so much control how did
this come out like how am I having such
a cool position here write down 300 cuz
black has some pawns to it has one extra
pawn yeah so 9f5
that's interesting
I was thinking of just g4
oh no my queen the Queen still hanging
this time I'm not meeting oh the oh no
emotes da the Windows updates as even
worse than blundering a queen when
Windows just wants to update I always
have to press snooze
okay so I've played g4 twice already
this game twice in the first 12 moves if
takes I could take back with night I
could also maybe take that with a pawn I
don't know
and the rooks also kind of hanging way
doing this Queen ji-sun Queen g7 was
also maybe possible idea of 97 clock
please interesting
and I just want to take the night
but if I take the night then I actually
lose my queen but maybe it's not so bad
try and calculate takes takes takes
Keeney seven it looks really fun they
sit at a three
let's do it
queen is just like sandwich between all
the pawns but the the prospect of Knight
f6 is it should be quite terrifying for
black though clock might simplify here
be unfortunate okay and black could have
taken but key nice islands nice to see
so the original intention was Bishop so
Bishop III don't think there's any any
other great candidate move I mean it's
very close to me that I can just like
somehow check the king
that's hard to do okay so let's play
this
that's all the pawns pinned so if they
checks I take back it's all good but
what to do next I could take on each
Saturn actually
hi Eric I am in st. Louis which is out
of state but it's it's a capital of
chess in the US I feel like you've you
got zapped before right also living in
the state of mind
searching for searching for the
checkmate okay
wait it's a material imbalance so I have
I don't care about my C pod or Dubai mg6
I'm scared of trading but have to go for
it
so material-wise black has a queen and
rook for two minor is a pawn so a very
unusual material imbalance Bishop g5 oh
no bishop gee I was imagining my bishop
coming I've not used to to it being on
v1 I do have that six though f6 is
interesting
it's plastics
as a fascinating position
I saw move back why not this is like a
really like these pawns are basically
worth a queen probably I think
but I don't know if it's enough to win
at some point blacks probably gonna sack
but I do have everything like night
helps nights do help reinforce the pawns
Jack okay this is this is feeling like
happiness and then Bishop I fade in the
very end the so Oh though the King has
to move back I'm still gonna have fish
my face it's a nice move coming off the
rook and then I'll Queen the pawn wow
that that worked out really nicely I was
like a positional boat as gambit where I
I sacked the Queen kind of accepting a
long term material deficit but
positionally I had I had met the pawns
rolling honestly when I played g6 I I
was envisioning that the bishop on c1
but it's still like guess worked maybe
box should have taken objectively a box
probably better here but there is always
some like weird compensation
yeah what does sawfish say about this
position I don't think why it's too much
worse maybe like -1 let's see okay mines
close to minus 3
yeah the slightly nuts I was a fun game
I was not expecting like the position to
get so crazy so quickly sawfish is not
so impressed with Queen f6 but actually
wow we have 6 isn't a bad move I guess
ok here it's not a bad move but like
playing g4 yeah it's not not too
impressed and I insisted on the Queen
sac it's a fun rollercoaster ride
yeah maybe that will go on YouTube a
positional boat s gambit but stock fish
really not impressed okay twitch chat is
saying hi to YouTube YouTube say hi to
twitch chat
say hi to to all the people Brian say hi
to Brian say hi to pain Express and oh
maybe future chilled acts can say hi to
past chill jacks